he's had that stuff ooh i'm not sure
that look look okay if le'veon bell
you're right this all works if le'veon
bell is the same guy we saw in
pittsburgh uh before he took his time to
it or even close to it all right even if
he's close to it oh it's a problem if
he's the same leviant bell i do wonder
in the back of my mind i keep wondering
okay is this the same guy i know he's
only 28.
but he took a year off
came back
with the jets was not good okay
uh
and he wasn't good this okay so he
hasn't been good since 2017.
i hear you
so whatever you can just say it doesn't
just
work like that you can just kind of
summon it get it back and oh and now i'm
the same let me on bill that's one two
you remember the reason he had his
contract dispute in pittsburgh in the
first place
he remember he compared himself to
he compared himself i'm the steph curry
of this thing i'm changing the game you
know look at me i don't know if he
compared himself to her we did yeah he's
running so he did no he did it he did it
okay
he called himself he said i'm like steph
curry i'm changing the game yeah the
running style yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right
i don't know if he is ready if he has
accepted that he is a complimentary
player in this offense
he should know you're not going to save
the kansas city chiefs they won the
super bowl without you they were scoring
a bunch of points without you i don't
know remains to be seen let's not
dismiss it let's not dismiss it
i gotta i gotta
i gotta think andy reid had that
conversation with him number one before
they signed number two you just left the
jets
okay
you have now the you just went to the
chiefs you went from a team that was
winless to a team that's looking to win
a second straight super bowl i have a
heart and not to mention
the worst thing you can do is go there
and be a problem
on a one-year deal or or on your
contract because if he's gonna hit
frequency next year you want to have put
something good on tape and something
good in terms of your reputation in
kansas city so the last thing will be is
a problem i'll give you that he might
not be the same player and maybe we're
overreacting maybe he's not the mind
stone maybe this is not another weapon
but all i'm saying is he doesn't need to
be great
the most overrated stone in my mind is
the reality stone didn't really do much
for me compared to the other ones
but we got to get it back
you didn't have to be great got to go
back all he is is a peace he's a peace
this is what we got to do somebody's got
to go back
to texas tech and change history and
keep patrick holmes
from the field and just like mess him up
a little bit more
keep him from so he is not a kansas city
chief anymore something like that or go
back to draft day or i don't know
hey hey ryan pace i don't know
let's go back and you know drive patrick
that's the only way you stop
you ain't got to move up you don't have
to move up to two stay where you are at
three
and take patrick my home
and the and the chicago bears for the
first time in their history
and have a quarterback
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports